the gyro can experience so I've been on
the carnivore diet tell you about that
yeah that's like a healthier keto right
or better way to do I don't know it's
just all meat just everything's meat I'm
not eating in any of any grains and I'm
not eating any carbs nothing else I mean
I have like an olive good add a Bloody
Mary
this is [ __ ] hob and olive so it's
not the most strict
occasionally I'll deviate I'm allowing
myself to glasses of wine and most of
the rest of [ __ ] I'm just drinking easy
to water or he's killed cliffs the CBD
killed cliffs [ __ ] carnivores like keto
but you're allowed to have fruit or
something meat you just eating meat like
mostly meat and because I eat a lot of
wild game I have to substitute it so
I've to supplement it with fat I'm
adding other fats to it cuz wild game it
does not have much fat and you can when
I read about the people that did this in
the reserve there was a guy that was
with the Inuit he was an explorer in the
Arctic and he was talking about how he
lived like that for six months and then
it was one of saw the video somewhere
online but his old black-and-white
footage and that the key was getting a
lot of fat they were just drinking water
and eating meat and he they were fine as
long as they got a lot of fat they with
the like whale blubber and polar bear
blubber and they would eat all this
blubber to sort of supplement their
therefore their fat intake they say he
was very healthy eating like that I'm
just doing it as an experiment that you
found a guy oh look at that probably I
would imagine this is probably a truth
about the Inuit diet maybe not they
didn't need any vegetables man oh it's a
long one too but yeah those people
didn't need any vegetables I'm just
curious
I'm just giving it a shot there's they
call it world carnivore Mont so I said
okay let me see what Jordan Peterson is
the main reason I want to try it because
I really respect his thought process and
I really respect his mind and when he
started talking about all the different
medical benefits that he had from trying
it and then he had autoimmune diseases
that went away and I'm like hmm what is
this and I know a bunch of people
personally they've tried it too
the gentleman thinks oh yeah yep that's
him yes the Homer yeah so he lived up
with the Antarctic what's interesting is
he said that they didn't eat the organ
meat they gave the organ meat to the
dogs I thought that was really weird
because that's definitely been proven to
be the yeah that's the guy right there
give me some volume on this dude could
we do that why would I get us in trouble
I don't know if this is in the open
domain anyway we just I just
I'll just encapsulate what he said he
just basically said that as long as they
had yeah that's the guy as long as they
had plenty of fat I'm just seeing what
it feels like it's weird I'll tell you
one thing I do not trust my butthole
at all mm-hmm I feel far coming on like
others could be a disaster I've had
rocketing diarrhea from meat that's from
all meat yeah this is what dr. Shaun
Baker who's like one of the head
carnivore proponents it's like his whole
life revolves around eating steak and
deadlifting it's kind of hilarious and
getting people to eat meat and try this
carnivore diet and some of them have had
some pretty radical health benefits and
I'm so curious about that because I know
that sometimes people convince
themselves that something is better for
them and that something is working
better and they feel better and then
there's a sort of a placebo effect that
can happen when you join a community of
people that's also saying the same thing
like we're all getting better we're all
feeling better so I was real hesitant
when I first went into it I was like if
I've I got I need to know there's
there's something to this or this is a
nonsense way to eat because most of my
thought process was this kind of a
nonsense we should eat some fiber this
clearly benefits eating some vegetables
but what's interesting is the the level
of energy or your energy level it's like
right here stays it doesn't go anywhere
it doesn't go anywhere
I mean at the end of the day I'm kind of
tired and then I go to sleep
that's weird man because how much of
your energy levels during the day is
based on your body regulating sugar and
insulin how much of it
how much is your energy level is based
on that it
might be a lot this is because this is
the the unquestionable difference of
this diet unquestionable difference is
that my energy level basically has a
flat line
there's no roller coaster anymore and I
had less of a roller coaster because I'm
pretty healthy and I'm pretty strict
with what I eat but not like this this
is like this show so for the last nine
days or so whatever the [ __ ] it's been
I've had like an olive I had um does
your body constantly ptosis at all I
must
yeah I'm not checking it must it must be
in ketosis I mean I'm eating a lot of
fat I'm eating bacon with all these wild
game dishes everything I eat bacon with
because I need fat and I'm cooking
everything in beef tallow Wow and then
I'm getting like fatty meat to butter or
anything I'm using butter yeah you could
drink milk I mean the idea is like if
you were a carnivore you would take
everything out of the body the milk the
fat everything look man it's weird I I
see why people would be opposed to it
morally and ethically because you don't
it would require people to consume a lot
more animals because every if everybody
was eating meat all the time the
consumption the need would go up and to
be even more slaughter I got it it seems
like a grant you're gonna get really
bored quick duck very likely that's very
likely that I get really bored quick but
it's curious because if I think and I
don't necessarily think this I'm just
saying if I think this is the best way
for me to eat I'm not saying that I'm
trying it and I'm basically trying it
based on mark Bell and Chris Bell and
and even more Jordan because I've talked
in depth with Jordan about it Jordan
Peterson is a brilliant guy and when he
was describing his experiences with this
diet I was like wait how many people
have done this right how many modern
super intelligent well-read articulate
people like Jordan Peterson have done
this diet I bet it's a really really
small amount because socially it's
unappealing to even say you're gonna do
it's sort of a taboo you only meet oh
you're gonna eat all the meat you not if
you need any vegetables are you a baby
that's vegetables are good for you right
that's what everybody immediately thinks
I don't know if that's true though I
don't know that's true one of the things
that Shaun Baker said is that they were
there doing tests at Harvard with with
people who are on this diet for six
months or more I don't know
I'm interested so I did some blood work
today and I'll make that blood work
public that's cool yeah I mean
especially if there's anything wacky
with it
but then I'm gonna do it again at the
end of the month and I'll compare Wow
that's gonna be a long month I think
because I know when Kido I got so bored
all my kids are bored we're not eating
steak again like you don't have to eat
steak I have to eat steak you can eat
whatever you want we'll figure this out
we'll work it out how many ounces of
meat a day do you know like what you're
up to like well a four the good thing is
I have a lot of elk that's good but I'm
running through it you know I'm eating
some big-ass chunks of meat is there
something that you go to a lot like
chicken wings or something like that
just because it's easy
no eggs you can eat eggs makes it really
easy to digest too I just kind of go
down eggs are great you know I wish that
coyotes weren't real those [ __ ]
[Applause]